- Growing up in Montana, I feel like I had
kind of a special opportunity
just to be outside a lot.
That's kind of where a love
of wildlife started for me
that dies out in a lot of kids,
and for me it just continued.
Alright guys, so we just
finished up bear den.
This little guy hasn't been named yet.
My name's Wesley Larson,
I'm a masters student
working in wildlife conservation,
and in some circles I'm known as Griz Kid.
When I first started
deciding that I should get
into the wildlife field, I
found Dr. Tom Smith at BYU.
I started by working with polar bears
on Alaska's North Slope, and
then that kind of transitioned
into some black bear work down
here in Utah in Bryce Canyon.
Bryce Canyon, like other national parks
that do have bears, they've
had a kind of a history
with visitor conflict and with bears
that maybe are getting into campsites,
so what we're doing is
we're tracking the bears
to learn what habitats they're using,
just to see what the park could do better
to make it easier for
visitors to avoid bears.
What we're doing is
we're fitting black bears
with GPS collars, and then I'll go in
to the den with the bear to
inject it with some drugs.
The bear then falls
asleep, I can pull it out
and you know just give it a full check up.
It's probably the most scary thing we do
just because bears wake up, sometimes
they're really unhappy to see us.
Stay, stay, stay, get back.
Hey, stay.
- [Narrator] More backpacks.
- Get him.
I have had to crawl up trees after bears.
It's an interesting job for sure.
People do have this knee jerk reaction
to seeing an animal that's sedated
or an animal that's wearing a collar
and think that, you know,
it might be being hurt,
and the thing that they don't realize
is that we really care
about these animals,
probably more than just about anyone.
Getting out into the wilderness
and having these kind of experiences
helps you understand that
we depend on wildlife
and wildlife depends on
us, and that's really
what conservation is all about,
giving the space and the
respect to these animals
that they deserve and really learning
as much about them as we can.